et maintenant passe à un autre théo tôt
[Musique]
jean pagny romont soir
devant une femme messieurs
15 millions de disques vendus
alors jean tout dommage tant de bien
c'est le truc que je suis portugais j'ai
un peu après votre honneur non client
n'est pas venue ici pour parler de sa
situation fiscale nette de son dernier
album à rien car tu as un avocat de
choix je sais dire aussi de vol
c'est à dire quelle audace elle fiscaux
un temps dire quoi ça j'encule le fils
comporte une piste king
bon alors on se doit pas être facile
pour vous en ce moment c'est assez
simple rien sur les paradors peppers oui
votre réputation baisse qua non parce
qu'en même temps j'étais déçue mme j'ai
jamais été dans ses plans la cua ouais
ils ont essayé un moment de me faire des
procès et vous avez gagné un ils ont
perdu voilà quoi ils ont perdu leur
procès et leur appel voilà et quand
certains disent que j'ai été condamné
pour fraude fiscale je pense qu'ils
s'égarent parce que c'était un reliquat
de retard de déclaration de tva rien à
voir avec une fraude fiscale ce qui fait
que quand on dit ça à la télé on
pourrait se dire que non mais ici on dit
ou tu viens me rappelle mon client ici
pour son album on va en parler
commencera normalement je suis ici pour
mon album et j'ai un peu l'impression
que de toute façon je vais faire une de
mes dernières télé oui oui parce que
j'ai trouvé ça plus sympa
alors attendez attendez attendez j'ai
pas dit j'ai pas dit que j'arrêtais de
chanter
au maire domaine
moi moi je vais faire des disques je
vais faire des concerts mais c'est vrai
que je vais peut-être faire mes adieux à
la promo et à la télévision en me disant
que finalement pourquoi je suis à la
télé parce que je chante bien mais on ne
parle jamais de ça si non mais attends
le pognon le fisc le tarp et le machin
tout le bordel où tu dis ok moi je suis
bavard je raconte tout parce que je
cache rien je suis comme mademoiselle
sincère et honnête et un moment battu
trouve que ça fait un effet pervers et
que ça se retourne contre toi et la
meilleure manière est passé d'acheter un
peu d'air sur la zone et d'arrêter de
parler tout ce que je pense et ça me
retombe dessus et bien voilà mais toi tu
es obligé de faire de la télé oui moi je
suis pas obligé c'est vrai et oui alors
comme on vend du sénat très bien mais
justement à ce sénat va très bien j'ai
encore moins besoin d'aller faire de la
télé je suis équilibré comment mais j'ai
ma belle vie et les enfants inca et à l
comment vont-ils très bien il faut
l'étudier sérieusement vous aviez fumé
quoi le jour de les choisir les prénoms
alors je vais te la raconter pourquoi
pas magna cherchait non on a cherché des
prénoms qui pouvait aller aux garçons ou
filles parce qu'on voulait pas savoir ce
qu'on allait avoir un ce qui fait que
jusqu'au dernier moment ça pouvait être
une fille qui s'appelait inca est un
garçon qui s'appelait à elle voilà
alors on va parler de votre nouvel album
donc
aussi pas mal
aussi fait
[Applaudissements]
or et argent aurait pas chier c'est de
la musique mais non mais non mais selon
le type qui s'appelle le premier tiers
non non pas du tout le présent d'abord
mais est ce que vous l'avez enregistré
directement vous êtes passé par une
société écran panama panama je les fais
panama panama panama et c'était super
sympa alors ça s'appelle le présent
d'abord le présent d'abord c'est une
philosophie de vie j'imagine où je suis
passé padduc rappel de carpe diem ouais
c'est ça le présent d'abord tu vois
voilà maintenant mais on est là elle
frédéric lopez et on vit ça mais non
mais c'est vrai ça va on vous observons
c'est compliqué de tout à coup entendre
dois-je obligés à ce jour ne défendrait
intense et c'est que déjà mal à défendre
on tâte agressive mais si florent ne
répond plus aux questions sur moi je ne
sais pas ne pas répondre ça me saoule
j'en ai marre j'en ai marre des
journalistes le mec du sept à huit
pétales son reportage il était super
c'est cette voix off de merde où ça ne
parle que de pognon ça parle que de
choses dégueulasses on peut dire vous
c'est important parce que j'ai
l'impression de comprendre tout ce qu'il
dit et j'ai besoin que ceux qui nous
regardent compagne tous qui dit et je
pense que vous comprenez tout ce qui n'a
bien entendu et donc ce qui est
troublant c'est que là il est dans un
domaine bienveillant et c'est que vous
l'aimez bien mais c'est pas tout le
temps comme ça en fait vous vous êtes en
train de faire des vannes sur la rumeur
oui mais vous vous savez qui paie ses
impôts
je peux dire un petit truc mais soit
florent élude l'impôt dans son pays et
ne participent pas à l'effort collectif
et c'est le mélange un vrai temps les 10
3 millions un bond de l'homme et soit
soit mais il règles sont les règles on
est obligé de les payer moi je suis
franco français essaye de te défendre
mais je ne dis pas que tu m'attaques
j'essaie de préciser une chose que tout
le monde n'arrive pas à comprendre c'est
qu'à un moment nous quand on fait ce
qu'on fait nos prestations elles sont
sur le territoire français eh bien on
paye le taux français en france la wii
c'est tout et donc je dis ce soit il
élude l'effort que nous devons tous
faire pour nos pays et dans ce cas c'est
un [ __ ] et dans ce cas il faut pas
l'inviter sur un plat tout télé soit il
ne fait pas ça me plaît dans son cadet
wii est dans ce cadre qu il invite et tu
parles de sa carrière c'est bien sûr
j'ai su
alors parlons de l'album alors votre
album s'appelle le présent d'abord c'est
une philosophie de vie en fait non ce
qui compte est présent à l'instant
présent comment vous sentez-vous en s y
faire il vaut mieux considérer son
instant présent que de traîner dans du
passé ou deux par ailleurs un futur
qu'on ne connaît vraiment apprécié a
passé trop de temps dans des réseaux
sociaux donc vaut mieux ou dans la tête
donc il vaut mieux ville chef déjà vendu
cent mille exemplaires de cet album est
un album qui a été fait en collaboration
et maître gims et produit par son alter
ego dany st t il ya une fois ce que
j'adore dans le parisien c'est florent
pagny s'offre un coup de jeune sans
faire de jeunisme c'est vrai que vous
êtes toujours quand même vous surfez sur
l'air du temps moi j'ai je me suis
positionné à quelques années comme un
interprète donc tu as la liberté de
pouvoir aller choisir des chansons dans
plein de milieux différents et il ya des
générations qui arrivent ou tu fais et
les gars ça vous amuse de de collaborer
avec un avec un jeune vieux ou un vieux
jeune et parce qu'il faut aussi qu'ils
aient envie de t'apporter les chansons
les bonnes chansons il ya un truc quand
même qu'ils aient constance c'est vous
avez en commun d'ailleurs avec maître
gims et l'amour des grandes mélodies oui
ça c'est un vrai point commun avec gims
l'amour des mélodies mais en fait ça
vient aussi beaucoup de la texture de la
voix qu'on peut avoir c'est à dire avec
le côté un peu opératique où on peut se
balader sur des lignes mélodiques un peu
un peu coloré et moi c'est vrai que
voilà j'ai c'est un peu mon terrain vous
êtes toujours la patate c'est une
chanson qui s'appelle je veux en voir
encore vous vous dites je veux en voir
encore des ko debout et des médailles
d'or ne vais pas raccrocher les gants
quoi oh non non non en fait on se dit à
temps malgré tout ce qui peut arriver
malgré tout ce qu'on a vécu vous malgré
tout ce qu'on peut subir ne nous
laissons pas écraser levant la tête et
encore plein de choses à faire et a lyon
la patate et allons nous battre et donc
laisser les moines qui m'ont envoyé ses
chansons et les chansons et j'arrivais
c'est peut-être slimane il m'amène une
chanson lors slimane c'était mon talent
dans ses boys ouais et là d'un seul coup
c'est lui qui est venu me coacher et moi
qui suis allé interprété sa chanson et
c'était sa traitait du même sujet ou il
faut où il faut changer les choses ou on
va changer les choses jusqu'à la fin on
arrive avec une dessine dessine un jour
nouveauté là mais les mômes israël ils
ont envie que ça bouge ils ont envie que
ça change mais ils ont envie d'aller
vers le positif vers et c'est vrai qu'à
la fin je fini par dire le [ __ ]
d'album c'est presque un médicament
tulle écoute en boucle et ça t'enlève
c'est de morosité ça t'enlève cette
tristesse et presque cette peur et cette
lâcheté en disant hé ouais je peux aussi
bouger mon cul et faire quelque chose et
si je peux devenir la voix de cette
génération là bas super je suis super
content
laurent banide en tournée dans toute la
france et à l'accord hôtel arena le 5
mars merci 2018 à bercy oui disons parce
qu'ils ont bercy alors quand on voit la
pochette là on voit que c'est vraiment
une invitation au voyage dans la chanson
qui s'appelle gandhi gandhi c'est le
vrai prénom en fait de maître gims vous
dit tu vas où tu veux va où sa vie bah
comme tu peux mais reste passe sa vie la
preuve est la preuve tu bouges d'ici là
voix oui thierry ici au standard j'ai
pour florent pagny 98 % d'opinions
favorables
interrogé sur les 2 % qui manquent
alors moi j'ai appris ça de stars c'est
à dire quoi j'ai vu ce mec-là bouger
prendre un avion tous les trois jours là
où tout le monde pourrait se dire quelle
fatigue et le mec est toujours hop hop
il vieillit pas ouais et tu te dis ça
peut être une vraie solution essayons et
depuis j'ai pris voilà j'ai pris cette
habitude de voyager et d'être tous les 3
jours toutes les semaines oui dans un
avion et dans un endroit et je dors pas
plus de dix jours dans le même lit quoi
florent pagny il n'y a pas besoin de
beaucoup le pousser pour qu'il fasse des
voyages
[Musique]
bien mérité cent
vous êtes le petit va faire sa valise en
dernier et il est trop cage florent
pagny vous auriez dit que vous alliez au
portugal pour le fado et la morue
personnes vous aurez emmerder mais enfin
mais vous dites j'y vais pour les arts
et non c'est là vous êtes trop tard mais
c'est pas du tout en fait la question
c'était où vous vivez oui et la réponse
est bas je suis un peu en patagonie je
vais en amérique pour voir les mômes je
suis un peu en france et villages atari
même au portugal voilà bon pourquoi le
portugal 1 mais moi si tu me dis pas ce
que j'ai dans un collège et oui mais moi
je sais pas mentir alors quand on me dit
pourquoi le portugal c'est latif et
aulas lui mais dans le même interview il
éclate à la fin parce que quand j'ai
fini tout le monde développé sur le
portugal j maintenant tout ce que je
viens de te raconter c'est pour toi
ouais tu le gardes pour toi dans le
parisien absolument sagement emploi
sérieusement honnêtement au delà de tout
ça c'est vrai qu'à notre époque c'est
très difficile de pas être politiquement
correct c'est que dès qu'il ya quelqu'un
qui sort du troupeau écoule sa gueule il
se fait massacrer rendu à coire est ce
que tu es beaucoup à l'étranger mais
aujourd'hui on ne peut même plus soulevé
la jupe de nolwenn
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
1 pouces bleus